I practice law every day in the
relationship between law enforcement and
prosecutors incestuous because every
prosecutor relies on law enforcement to
make their cases and so it's kind of
hard for you to then go in the family
and ask that same prosecutor to
prosecute somebody who's been helping
them make cases you have a new police
misconduct Division of the Department of
Justice that's dedicated just to
answering complaints and investigating
police misconduct the independent
investigators would be a game-changer
because if you're a citizen you call the
feds and the feds job is actually to
respond to you it's not like to try and
bury your complaint under a rug
[Music]
very happy to welcome to yang speaks
South Carolina leader son and nephew of
civil rights icons commentator on what's
happening right now and really for the
last number of decades in American life
where race is concerned but also now a
newly minted author just wrote a book my
vanishing country which I've read and
enjoyed a great deal and it gives you a
sense of the historical arc of many of
the things we're facing as a country
today mr. Bakari sellers welcome Bakari
thank you so much for having me Andrew
I've I've always admired you I love the
work that you're doing your race for
President of the United States your
campaign invigorated and brought more
people into the process and now I get to
call you a co-worker and a colleague and
it's just your voice is refreshing and
so thank you for everything and thank
you for welcoming me to the to the yang
gang Oh thrilled to have you here
Bakari you know I mean you're you're
such an important figure I saw your
emotional reaction on TV about George
Floyd and and what's happened in your
you have one boy and one girl is that
right I know they're 21 I have twins at
one boy one girl and I have a 15 year
old and so you know when I think back on
that moment I'm Andru it for me I was
coming on and you know how this goes
sometimes I was coming on TV after
George Floyd's brother and he was really
emotional and you know I was just
thinking about the fact that he laid
dead in the street I was think about the
fact that the officer had his knee on
his neck for eight minutes three of
which he was three of which he was
already dead didn't give him the benefit
of his humanity and I began to think
what would I tell my children how was I
going to raise my children in a world
where there is a segment of the
population that does not give them the
benefit
their humanity and for me it was just it
was it was that level of disrespect that
they showed George but it's over and
over again you know my father's
generation was Emmett Till Jimmie Lee
Jackson Medgar Evers the four little
girls in the 16th Street Baptist Church
and then for me it's not only my good
friend Clem in the Charleston massacre
which I write about but it's also
Georgia Maude Briana Trayvon Eric Alton
Walter
Keith Sameer Sandra I mean the list goes
on and on and on and I think right now
people have to realize in this moment
we're having a moment that's not just
about George Floyd but it's also about
years and decades and centuries of
systemic racism and institutionalized
oppression you know we have a crisis
that's on top of a crisis on top of
decades and decades of structural racism
and the fact that you you've obviously
internalized each victim that we know
about and we all know that for every
victim you just listed there must be
dozens hundreds of others that we'll
never hear about correct that just no
one had a smartphone handy or the
narrative never reached the public eye
one of the things that I found most
difficult to stomach when I was looking
into these issues when I was running for
president because oh there was a huge
need for criminal justice reform and
addressing police brutality before this
crisis we don't even know how many
people are shot and killed by police
officers every year or died in police
custody yeah and you know one of the
things I think about is going back to
you all's campaign who Leon Castro
actually got this right who Leon was one
of the he had one of the the more bold
visions on this but the things we can do
Andrew and that's what you know I don't
like the people who were telling us to
just go and wait to vote in Nova
I just that that doesn't do us any good
because at the rate that killing black
folk that's gonna be about another five
six seven bodies between now and
November but I want people to talk about
limiting qualified immunity in civil
suits that we bring against bad police
officers and bad police departments I
want people to talk about lowering the
standard by which you can bring federal
criminal civil rights charges against
law enforcement officers I want a
national standardized use of force
guidelines and training I want a
national database because right now you
can be a bad cop in one city and go to
cut two cities down and get another job
I want the officers arrested in George
Floyd's case so I mean these are things
that we can talk about doing now
structural change and reform and at the
way that we police right now
but we seem to be absent leadership and
you know as Democrats sometimes I say
that we we legislate with a stop sign
like we never we never go big enough we
never go bowed enough we never go
creative enough we never go progressive
enough and I think that this is the time
in which we have to do them I could not
agree more
I think being told like hey wait for
five months and like head to the ballot
box I mean there's so much urgency and
energy and passion and grief and despair
and I understand people looking up and
saying has not been working for us
for years decades like you know why
would we expect it to change with any
one election so but let's go through
those measures one by one because I
think they're so important so when I
looked at this again like with you
number one I'm like a data guy so the
first thing I think is like okay like
how many people does this kill every
year and then when you know you can't
find that out then you're like oh
like that's really that's like very very
because you know like there's a police
department where you know someone shoots
shoots an unarmed black man in the dead
of night and you're just like oh well
well let's just like say that the person
like you know attacked fled was armed
like the officers would just say they
were scared I mean the the you the the
wild thing is that this officer Chauvin
had 18 complaints against him now I know
some people just file frivolous
complaints sometimes but 18 is a whole
lot or in the case of David McAtee one
of the cases that we're seeing now at at
Louisville they called him they called
him to barbecue man and he literally in
his barbecue restaurant fed cops for
free so imagine you feed cops for free
and are now gunned down by cops and you
talk about the evidence or lack thereof
when you're talking about data well you
know they're body cam footage wasn't on
so you know how do we even figure out
what happened so you you had these
things and like you said we can start
with the data I think that's important
and from that data we can mine other
good ideas but I do think that there has
to be some standardized and nationalized
things that we do starting with data of
course but also starting with the use of
force and in making sure that for
example chokeholds aren't allowed in one
district and in department but allowed
in another well I I met with a black
lives matter activist in New York Park
Newsome who said to me said like look
here's the problem and this this struck
me as true he said so let's say you have
a dirty cop does something terrible in
an area the local district attorneys
literally work with law enforcement
day-in day-out and if you're the mayor
of that town law enforcement s--
possibly the most important constituent
see you have where if they turn on you
you're
and so you're looking at and saying okay
let's see the DA the May
like no one has a real interest in
trying to root out like bad cops or
confront them on brutal behavior and so
what Hawke said to me was like you need
someone from the outside of that area
and Kamala said this yesterday to
something similar she said it needs to
be like the state attorney general which
which strikes me is still too close to
the the area because if you're like you
know the the state AG's still probably
knows a lot of the same people so what I
what I would say is I practice law every
day and I'm criminal criminal lawyer I
do it all the only things I don't do or
immigration and family law in the
relationship between law enforcement and
prosecutors incestuous because every
prosecutor relies on law enforcement to
make their cases and so it's kind of
hard for you to then go in the family
and ask that same prosecutor to
prosecute somebody who's been helping
them make cases for the past you know
decade plus and so you need those
outside independent investigators to
come in and handle these cases outside
independent prosecutors to handle these
cases I think it's going to be very
interesting with with Kela keith Ellison
handling this case as the attorney
general in Minnesota that's gonna be
very interesting but nationwide we have
to see independent investigators of of
law enforcement shootings and you know
it's no excuse to have your it's no
excuse to have your your body cannot on
you know it's it's it's no excuse that
we don't have that we don't have use of
force training and de-escalation
training and manuals around that we can
actually pick up and see because it's
not only the data but it's the lack of
transparency yeah
let me put it to you this way Brianna
Taylor and George Floyd funded the
departments that killed them and what I
mean by that is our tax dollars go to
the Department of Justice who issues
grants to these departments we don't
have any clawback mechanisms but these
departments have no transparency have no
civilian oversight we don't know their
training mechanisms but yet our tax
dollars go to them and so I think that
we
I'm not saying defund but what I am
saying is that we need to have some
accountability measures in place with
our tax dollars to go to this deeply so
this is my I proposal that I I put out
on social media and some people loved it
actually got much more love than
anything else so if you take as a given
that local district attorneys and
officials are going to have a hard time
confronting police misconduct in their
area because of the incestuous
relationships that you just described
and you need someone independent now now
I looked at the Department of Justice
guidelines and after the Rodney King
riots they passed a law saying that that
the Department of Justice can
investigate police departments for
systemic problems as they did with the
LAPD as a practice in it but you know
violating constitutional rights and
equal rights that happens very very
seldom it's happened I believe once in
the entire Trump administration and it
strikes me as willfully insufficient so
the proposal is that you have a new
police misconduct Division of the
Department of Justice that's dedicated
just to answering complaints and
investigating police misconduct if you
were a really good DA or mayor you
actually welcome this cuz you're like oh
good like you know I didn't want to have
to pick a fight with like the the local
law enforcement but the feds are here
you named it after George Floyd you fund
it and then you have an army of
investigators who are just following up
to see what like you know it's like hey
there are a lot of complaints against
this Derek shavon character like
eighteen of them you know it's like or
you're coming in hopefully before the
fact you're completely immune from
political influence your job is just to
try and root out bad cops I suggested
that Val Demmings run it someone that
people would be excited about because
she has a law enforcement background and
and you know and so because and then
most people saw this proposal and said
like yes that this could be he could be
on to something here
other people took the like like no we
should defund essentially like what your
original which like I looked at it and
say look there are 18,000 police
departments around the country getting
funded in all sorts of ways by like
municipalities and property tax on the
rest of it it's it's like like I
understand the impulse but it to me it's
much more practical to actually like
someone who's like an independent actor
who doesn't have ties the community
their entire measurements are just
around trying to root out please
misconduct and then you could also get
better data because you'd have a
department that's dedicated to it I
agree with you wholeheartedly I mean
there are a few things one patterns and
practice investigations in law
enforcement literally take about the
entire presidency before they're
completed before you can actually issue
a consent order or something of that
nature they take forever they're too
long and as you say it they're willfully
inadequate but not only should cities
and local elected officials welcome it
but good cops should welcome it too
because you're shining some light in and
you don't have to worry about you you
don't have to worry about what's going
on and who's protecting you or who
you're serving with because you're a
good cop but you do know that there are
others there who who were reviewing
these things and I think about Demmings
is so dope I love I love about dimming
zai mean she's been she's been an
absolute superstar you never know I
think she might have some vice-president
maybe she can run the George Floyd
please miss Conway but having but having
this independent arbiter arbiter of of
you know misconduct I think is very very
valid and it speeds up justice I mean
we're sitting here today and you know
the officers still have not been
arrested and hopefully that changes you
know we're not sure I agree with Rand
Paul weirdly and weirdly enough about no
not warrants in Louisville in the case
of Brianna Taylor
they literally I mean they just released
her boyfriend who shot back I mean he
did something that most people would do
people kick down the door of your house
with like guns out you might you know he
wake up startled you're gonna shoot back
you know and so they could drop the
charges but we just have so many reforms
at
you know I think that you would agree
with me that this passive attitude that
even some Democrats are taking now where
you're like where we're asking for peace
but we're not asking for justice and
we're telling people to go home without
anything to do or without any strategy
or without any aspirations or goals I
think is is a mistake I agree man I'm
not doing that because I understand the
anger it's like and people have been
rightfully pointing out it's like this
has been going on under Democrats
and Republicans and they're like
different administration's and it's not
like you know if you just win an
election like all of a sudden black
people are safe in their neighborhoods I
mean we all know it's just not true
well I I this discussion is refreshing
because it's one this that you know it
abides by the policy guidelines that I
set forth in my head and that's when I
put my legislative hat back on which is
you know I am tired of Democrats and
Republicans just proposing these
race-neutral policies for very very
specific problems we have right I'm not
a big believer in rising tide lifts all
boats I do think that we have to have
and you talk about this as well when it
comes to capital and directing resources
directly yeah sure yeah so freaking
money into people's hands like that that
would help too I mean George Floyd died
because he was like allegedly you know
using like a counterfeit $20 bill I mean
you know like is that the situation if
he got two thousand dollars a month in
relief let's say forever hypothetically
you know yeah I mean yeah I agree with
you I I think that we have to you know
I've come around on on ubi
I don't think it can supplant or Sur
plant some of the safety net programs we
have you know I don't know it does too
but I do believe that that what works
what we've exposed and one of the things
I talk about in my book is for me it's
not about somebody calling me by
the way cuz you're like I get called
like that all the time believe that free
kid like exactly but Stokely pointed out
you know I always refer to stokeley's
uncle Stokely would always say that you
know we have to define racism and racism
is if you if you want to lynch me that's
your problem but if you
the power to lynch me that's my problem
right and so it's a power construct and
it's about systems right
it's about systems and institutionalized
racism and so one of the things that
I've always always always talked about
is the fact that if you take if you take
this pandemic if you want to peel the
layers back you would appreciate this
because now we have data we have data
that shows us that black people are
dying disproportionately the Native
Americans and the question is why and I
go back and I'm like it's not just you
know get more vitamin D stop drinking
stop smoking it's the fact that as I
outlined in my vanishing country like
you know you grow up in a food desert
where you can't have healthy food
alternatives you you're drinking dirty
water you're breathing in polluted air
you know you you live next to a brown
field or a manufacturing plant you're
going to schools that are broken down I
mean all of these things contribute to
the comorbidities contribute to the
preventable diseases and then you
overlay a pandemic I mean he'll like you
know the same when America gets the gets
a cold black folks get the flu
well now America has kovat and black
folk are dying and that is the reason
why because of these systemic and
Justices we have in this country and so
right now you know racism and those
systemic rates that racism is killing
people two ways through kovat and you
know on the streets or at the hands of
law enforcement and you know we haven't
we haven't really addressed that and one
of the ways that you know we've peeled
the layer back when we look at the data
I think that you know when you talk
about a UV ubi that is one way to that's
one way in which we can help improve
some of these systems and improve the
culture and many of these communities to
me Bakari and I said this on the trail
words hurt numbers kill you know if you
have systemic poverty and people have
high blood pressure and all these I you
know diabetes and all these health
problems because they live in a food
desert
they're food insecure they're they don't
know where their next rent check or
paycheck is gonna come from
that's also very very stressful you know
you like elevated
as elevated mental health problems and
anxiety and everything else that like
the numbers are the the thing that we
can actually address if we all get
together as a country and say hey guess
what we're tired of people being poor
$2,000 a month and this is what Martin
Luther King was fighting for when he was
killed and you know Timmy his memories
has been sanitized do you have this like
celebrate his birthday like you know I
have a dream and it's like you know you
don't say you don't see every freaking
year it's like universal basically give
everyone you know I talk about I talk
about that in a book too I remind people
often it the last Gallup poll they did
of King I think it was 64 but it might
have been 66 I think it was 64 his
approval rating was in the low 30s and
Donald Trump's approval rating stays
between 40 and 48 so when people
oftentimes bring up dr. King I'm like
you do remember that you know not only
did you kill him but he really wasn't
well liked when he died because he was a
revolutionary and he's been whitewashed
and many of the things I mean people
don't even understand how he died why he
died and how he was fighting for the the
rights of sanitation workers in Memphis
Tennessee yeah he was fighting for UVI
he was fighting for improved can work
and worker conditions and just improving
the plight in the load of everyday
people of color and everyday working
people which we have to one of the
things we have to do and and I one of
the reasons I wrote this book is because
we have to flip the narrative on his
head that working-class means white in
rural means white and urban means black
like we have to kind of disavow ourself
and disabuse ourselves of those notions
but yes you're right dr. King was a
revolutionary whose legacy has been
white life I know there's so many
arresting or like affecting stories from
your book I mean certainly your father's
story I mean I feel like he was very
lucky to be alive
like it's clear that yes that some
people intended him harm and and you
know three other people lost their lives
the Orangeburg massacre which I agree
with you also is very much overlooked in
history and I can't imagine what it's
like to have that be your family's
lineage like
your your family's history there's also
the start of your friend pop from
childhood who just seemed like yes
instinctively I just really like them
you know it seemed like such a great guy
and you know he he went to college had
to better himself
you know became a parent but still
struggled mightily yeah and yes and that
that hurt because you know there's this
myth of the American Dream where if you
like you know try and do the right
things like you'll end up being able to
live a decent life and for many many
people including many of the people you
grew up with it's not true
you know my story of pop first of all
you never really realize how many
characters are in your life until you
begin to write about them I mean when
you write I can't wait to read your next
book Andrew but when you write about it
all these characters you meet and that
that play a role in your life and you
give them life in their own right and
give them a voice you're like wow these
people are really my friends are really
complex but pop is a story of love
challenge conflict but if you know if
pops a member of the yang gang and it or
he takes a minute to listen to this pod
I won't pop to know that he's a success
because his struggle his toils his
tribulations him trying to get over the
hump him trying to attain that American
Dream is going to create more
opportunity for his children and they
won't have to go through many of the
same things that pop did pop is will
always be my brother you know we he was
right we were raised together different
sizes attract different households all
right vividly about when Pop lost his
father and how he ended up coming over
to our house and living with us and him
being mad he wasn't invited to the
wedding and you know just just all of
these things these complicated
relationships but pop is pop is a pop is
a part of an America that people don't
want to see and don't want to talk about
and yeah it's one reason why your book
so important we have to let people know
that you know this is the norm new
normal or the old normal the same normal
in America and that we need to do
something about it
so it sounds like we have agreed on two
big things so far we need a new police
misconduct team of investigators that
are immune from local influence you know
and it sounds like we both want to get
rid of poverty you think like that would
help which I believe that would help
what do you think about this idea I've
been thinking about this in my head I
want to I want to push this country to
create a new infrastructure package
think it's bipartisan and along the same
lines of my race specific policy
proposals
I want this infrastructure to be in a
few buckets
you know innovative cutting-edge
technologies like high-speed railways
between major cities especially
throughout the south like Charlotte
Atlanta and those type things but I also
want to have broadband involved in it
I want basic basic utilities like water
involved in it because you know we we
still have dirty water in Flint Michigan
and in Martin South Carolina which is a
travesty and you know I want to say that
we set aside two trillion dollars or
five trillion dollars and of those
monies you know 10% has to go to my
already owned businesses right and of
the other the other remaining 90% they
have to have a minority hiring component
think about how that impacts in economy
think about how that lifts up minority
businesses think about how that gives
people jobs high-paying jobs and because
we'll have to cultivate and create a new
workforce think about those businesses
who will then partner with places like
HBCUs or other technical colleges to
help cultivate and build an entire new
labor force I just think that if we
focus on something like our country's
infrastructure to rebuild yes I think
that we can actually create an entire
new generation of wealth everyone should
be able to get behind this I can't
believe Trump didn't even build anything
I thought that this would be his jam
just so he could throw his name on it
but but he's a he's a horrible bill
apparently trillions of dollars in
infrastructure for everything from clean
water to broadband in rural communities
to 5g high-speed rail I mean that the
reality is our country's falling apart
like we were still a little literally
apart it's unsafe we
are coasting on investments that were
made decades ago and like now it's time
to reinvest it's past time and this used
to be bipartisan it's a symptom of just
how dysfunctional things of God and it
would and it would potentially
rejuvenate black communities and
communities around the country because
to your point let's say you know 10% of
two trillion would be like two hundred
billion dollars that went straight into
minority-owned businesses and
communities i and and you know III just
think about the ripple effect I mean you
these people you know you're gonna
you're gonna be working you're gonna be
in it's gonna take engineers these are
high-paying jobs etc these companies are
gonna have to invest in stem programs
and local communities to help build
pipelines and these are as you know
these projects take years if not decades
to complete so you're talking about a
constant stream of of a return of ROI I
mean these are your words and phrases I
mean I visited so I visited family in
Asia and there's a high-speed rail that
goes the equivalent in New York to DC in
like 75 80 minutes like what would would
be like a four-hour drive like a you
know an hour and 20 minute train ride
high-speed rail and it warps your sense
of the laws of time and space and it
also gave rise to whole new communities
that were let's call it like 60 miles
away from downtown but all of a sudden
that's like a 35 minute train ride so
then they just built it up because it's
like so it you know that's like a whole
new town so those are the possibilities
so we added a third we added a we added
a third thing we're at infrastructure to
so I mean we're rocking it we're fixing
all the world's problems we we did
policing we did poverty and now let's
policing because there's some other like
things that need to be done after even
you got I think the the independent
investigators would be a game-changer
because if you're a citizen you call the
feds and the feds job is actually to
respond to you it's not like to try and
bury your complaint under a rug so and
so I just want to unpack this a little
bit more because I dug into some of the
numbers right
communities are spending hundreds of
millions of dollars on payouts for
victims of police brutality
it's a massive line item in their
budgets like correct in North in North
Charleston they paid out six point five
million dollars for the murder of Walter
Scott out of their out of their just
city budget and you know you if you
weren't killing and shooting people in
the back maybe you could use that for I
don't know summer programs and ice we're
talking about human life but the fact is
like police brutality is very very
costly there's a like New York City
spent three hundred million on payouts
in a year three hundred million million
in in a year and that's independent of
the actual like lawyers fees because
that wasn't included like you know that
or insurance because like I'm sure they
had to they pay for that too so you're
talking about nationwide hundreds of
millions of dollars that are getting
spent essentially cleaning up after
dirty cops and that money could be
better spent it's also a sign of how big
the problem is because you know only a
fraction of these lawsuits are ever
seeing the light of day like the vast
majority just get you know it's like old
it's like you know like shot that
guy like you know he like he scared me
like that is thought that is awesome
enjoy the time as I might like a
lawsuits being brought so so if you see
that the successful lawsuits are
resulting in hundreds of millions of
dollars and liability in some cases
towns like had to cut back on other
services because they were stuck with
some freaking giant like you know and
you just think but think about if we
invested if we invested at 10% of that
on the front end yes like train so
that's what we have to go we have to
take this feedback loop or even pay them
more like I'm not opposed to paying good
cops so here was an idea I had Bakari I
hope you like it sounds like you're
gonna like it so what you do is you have
department-wide bonuses tied to
lower police brutality liability in a
given so like like well it's okay it's
okay I did what you mean like an
Allstate drive safe you get it yeah so
here's the thing it's like if you're a
part of like the NYPD and you're paying
300 million out and penalties then you
go to the members of the police
department and be like hey FYI like if
you get that down like we'll actually
distribute 10% of the reduction to
officers so like each of you can get
like a few hundred dollars at the end of
the year if you guys like get the
liability down and then some
does something you just like man
like you know like that actually like
cost me money that will I don't I don't
like I don't like incentivizing people
to be anti-racist however because the
problem is so exacerbated I don't think
that's a bad idea and I think that what
it does is it helps with you what you're
doing with that is you're changing
culture because now it's like it's like
everybody at home now and then you see
these fools out just like walking around
with no masks on and you feel like
you're a kindergarten class that can't
get recessed because of two people and
so you change the culture you start
having people in law enforcement they're
like dude you I mean let's not shoot the
let's not shoot the guy in the back
right like you don't have to beat him
right like we can get this extra few
dollars and I but I think that it would
actually build some level of because so
they come around here on good cops cuz
if you're a good cop then you're like
hey like because so one another study I
saw I must have been digging into this
but like bad cops are incredibly
expensive you know it's like like that
when you looked at it like a bad cop
generates lawsuits but like more like
they increase your insurance premiums
they're all these problems with a bad
cop so if you had measurements around a
police department essentially incurring
lower liabilities but hundred percent
agree with you though it's all about the
culture because right now the culture is
it's us against them with us defined as
law enforcement and them defined as
everyone else exactly I mean but in this
I mean but that just that's that so
American cuz right now we're at a point
where I can't even say black lives
matter I mean have you seen the last
just cuz they're so relevant and awesome
and Durham yeah it's so relevant like we
can't even agree on that like nobody
we're just saying it matters right we're
not we're not saying it matters more
than anything else we're just asking for
like its who matter and so one of the
things that one of the ways you were
able to break through in your race and
one of the things we have to duplicate
though is bringing new people into this
process and and creating a level of
understanding you know the biggest
problem we have in this country is we're
absent empathy I just don't think that
people have the want to put themselves
in other people's shoes I mean I tell
people all the time if you read my
vanishing country I want you to be able
to have a level of understanding and at
least just have some empathy for your
fellow man and understanding what it
means to be black in this country you
know TD jakes told me something so
poignant he said look and you would
agree with this he he said you can't he
said you could teach me math you can
teach me science you can teach me
English but you can't teach me blackness
and until we start to get understanding
of other people's cultures then we'll
never get to the level of empathy that
actually gets us to a point where we can
begin to heal and we need to see that in
all of our systems I mean we need to see
that not only in our policing we need to
see that in we need to see that level of
empathy in our infrastructure because
you don't want I mean you don't want
your daughter or son or whomever
drinking dirty water well so why should
I you want to you want to talk about it
in our educational system because of the
fact that kids are punished because of
the zip codes they're born into today
you've come to South Carolina you know
about the corridor shame where kids go
to school and they're heating an area
doesn't work and air infrastructures
falling apart
and so we have to be focused on
remitting knees you talked about in your
book man like the empathy of like our
health care system where they don't
listen to black women like like women
like say hey I'm in pain or this is
wrong with me and then like yeah I mean
I've seen I've seen out the brokenness
of our healthcare system from from three
angles like one living in a community
where we lost our Hospital one you know
we when you don't expand Medicaid that
that should happens and people don't
even know the economic impact of losing
a hospital it's not just a health care
impact but it's an economic impact
because you know what happens when you
lose your Hospital in small towns and
small communities that's usually your
number one employer so people are
unemployed and not only that but all the
small businesses around it the florist
the pharmacies this restaurants that all
spring off because of the hospital that
whole part of town just shuts down
so I lost my hospital almost lost my
wife in birth of our child last year we
talked about african-american female
mortality she hemorrhaged while giving
birth to my twins
thank God I mean I don't I don't know
again it sounds like you were you you
were a key part of the reason why she
survived because you raised the alarm
you have to you have to become an
advocate you got to become a champion
and for the first 30 36 hours of their
life she was in ICU so I saw it through
not only losing access to care but also
african-american female mortality and
the third thing is my daughter last year
had to have a liver transplant and you
know we we you I was able to see up
close and personal a very broken
transplant system that we have in this
country be where less than 5% of donors
are african-american but they we need
more because of these preventable and
comorbidities that we talked about we
need more access to organs and so just
from those three perspectives I haven't
and very interesting but yet personal
look on how we have to make sure that
everyone has access to the promises and
ideals of this country that I say and
believe are vanishing although I believe
we can reclaim it right now it's
vanishing before eyes yes well if
there's anyone who's going to help help
us reclaim it it's you and in yours
Bakari so you talked about national
training for police officers which I
also completely agree with my sense
right now is that there's like you know
a whole range of different training
approaches but most all of them seem to
Center on shooting to kill relatively
quickly like making snap decisions and
we need to have some national training
protocols and so I talked to someone who
who's in policing and he suggested that
we need more intermediate weapons as a
way to de-escalate like because right
now it seems like it's gun or nothing
and he was like look like yes you
theoretically have some other things but
like we need to like make it so
shooting with a lethal firearm is not
your first move I mean I also think that
and this is gonna be somewhat
sensationalized and a little bit
controversial but if you're inherently
afraid of black people like you don't
need to be on a law enforcement force
like if that's your fear if you were
just scared right you're always scared
that's not that's not something you
should do but I think that there are a
number of mechanisms and ways and
methods because we see it done with
other people often of de-escalating very
very tense situations that don't involve
you they rode up on Tamir rice and shot
him in like two seconds
playing with a toy gun that anybody who
you know would have been able to see
it's mean it's a 12 year old kid he was
a boy he was in a park playing with a
toy gun by himself like and they rode up
on him and shot him I mean the choke
hold that was used against Eric Gardner
and the standard is so high that Barack
Obama's Department of Justice wasn't
even able to bring charges against
penile onopen pronounce his last name
Daniel pen yeah so I mean you you just
you just Pantaleo you just we just have
so many things that can be done and it
seems like under Democrats and
Republicans nothing has been look here's
a really big part about Democrats it's
this it's not like Democrats to me
almost put too much faith in
institutions rules and bureaucracies
it's like oh we need like better we need
a better rule we need a better rule and
sometimes you got to look up and say
wait a minute like you know we actually
just need to do the thing whatever the
thing is and it's one reason why to me
exactly like we don't have the right
approach towards police brutality
because we have this half-hearted
Department of Justice oversight that
like you said takes years is only
available in certain cases isn't even
going after individuals it has to be
essentially like departmental policies
and and whatnot and it's one reason why
people are fed up like you look around
and
like oh right who the hell has
responsibility for this and you have a
system where it's a you know it's like
well everyone is looking around being
like I don't know who's responsible for
this and like you know that's why people
are so pissed off
yeah i and i think people and fannie lou
hamer said it best people are sick and
tired of being sick and tired and we've
gone and we've seen we've we've sent
many of the same elected officials back
year after year after year after year
and nothing's changed and you know we
have one of the most I can't I can't
leave this show I know we're getting
near the end but I can't leave this show
without telling people we got it we got
to participate in the census you know I
know that it seems wonky but the census
is freaking vital I mean I wish we could
kind of get near the end on something
different but the census is literally
how power is distributed in this country
is one of the most important things idea
man you and I should like rebrand the
census it's too late for this one but
maybe the nice one instead of calling it
the sets
oh yeah the marketing on the census is
horrible the MARTA that in every 10
years it doesn't get any better but we
have to digitize and rebrand the census
I mean that it's just so much to do and
we don't have a lot of time to fix it
either Andrew that's the time I mean the
country is literally on fire right now
and aren't you kind of glad though in
retrospect that you're not the next
president because think about think
about the mess you're gonna have to
clean up think about after do you know
like it's it's kind of like you it's
kind of like you you're the for example
you're the general manager after Bobby
Cox or you the quarterback after Brett
Favre or you're the coach after Dean
Smith all right that's not what you what
you want to do because the expectation
level for you is gonna be maybe that's a
horrible example because he's doing such
a poor job but it's gonna be a huge mess
it's gonna be a really really big job
for somebody and it's gonna be really
tough but I'd love to be coming in as
president cuz you know there's just so
much to do but I'm with you that we're
coming from like a very very deep dark
hole and like that the hole is claiming
people anyways claiming lives and and I
understand when people look at this and
being like like I feel I have no
recourse but to march on the streets
break curfew whatever the heck and you
know scream at the top of my lungs or
worse because no like we have this
inhuman system that's just been grinding
people up and
it's been grindin people of color up in
like the most gruesome inhuman way
possible and when you see this happen
you look up and say like you know what
choices I'll have you left me at this
point
you know it's like my political system
seems completely unresponsive you know
you have I said something that's like
pretending it's working is not working
you know and and and one of the things
that that like a lot of Democrats do is
just like come and say it's like hey you
know no things will be alright if you
like you know do this and do that for us
like you know get me in office or
whatever and it's like actually I have
the suspicion that even if you were in
office like all would change it
won't change exactly because we're not
we need more radical revolutionaries
injury and that's what ubi is and that's
what you are and that's what I'm trying
to be you know you're like I hope you
take this in a positive way but say
you're like me and that you're like a
revolutionary of like the heart or the
spirit and and one of the things that I
I worry about which I again completely
get is that people are looking up and
saying like you know like the the
empathy like why should I have empathy
for people who do not have empathy for
for me in mine or like the the the trust
has just been lost and it's very hard to
reclaim trust you know what I mean like
if it's been broken down over you know
meanwhile we all know that in the
relationships to you know it's like if
you're like you know if someone breaks
your trust like you're just like well
like that's that you know and and and
that's what's happened with way too many
Americans yeah like that the goal has to
be to try and reconstitute trust in like
a new set of people institutions leaders
oh look at that is that Stokely I'm
guessing hopefully he we tried to keep
him quiet for as long as possible but he
always he always finds a camera I don't
know why he likes the camera so much
maybe he got that from his daddy um well
he looks good he's a natural just like
his daddy and I have to say I'm like a
person level man I can't imagine what
it's like to be the son of civil rights
leaders and icons who you know marched
with dr. King and
Stokely Carmichael and like everyone
else I mean you you've obviously
inherited it like through action you
know you were like the youngest state
legislator and everybody else for me
though it's for me it's living a life
this purposeful that's intentional it's
it's about being a change agent being
part of something larger than yourself
and you know one of the things I always
tell people man I can't be free if we're
not all free and you're always on this
journey to improve the plight and
condition of those around you and that's
that's what I try to do I mean every
step that I take in you know people are
critical sometimes if I make a misstep
that's fine but just like you my heart's
always in the right place I think and
I'm always trying to make it more
purchase on man I mean you're fighting
for a little Stokely you're fighting for
the future of your family and your
community we need you more than ever
Bakari I'm so glad we've gotten to know
each other and congratulations on the
book like being a first-time author is
amazing yeah you like here you bearing
it all here I am so I'm literally an
open book now and I just have to thank
you for allowing me to use this platform
you have a huge platform and I'm
grateful in you know I hope people give
my vanishing country a chance especially
during this time so we can have that
understanding and we can begin to have
these conversations the most difficult
conversation in this country to have is
one on race but as you see like you and
I said here for an hour I had a
conversation but we talked about
solutions to which is necessary during
this book yeah I couldn't agree more
we have to get the solutions out there
front and center so that the energy and
the grief and the anger leads to a
better place
I'm more than grateful for you and your
team and the yang gang I led the yang
Kang that they're there they're all
they're everywhere in Jermaine Johnson
in South Carolina trying to get him over
this yeah so I hope more people run for
office yes you said they you sure it's
not we like we the guys I'm official now
all I need is a little hat I need a hat
or
i'ma add a hat to my Aviana weekend man
will send you the the real-life hat but
yeah like if you got the blue cap on
that would be tremendous you would make
us smarter better more empathetic and it
means a lot
thank you so much man thank you all the
best to you and your family man
[Music]